[Musik]
guten tag schön dass sie heute dabei
sind wir machen einen spaziergang mit
einem der bedeutendsten schweizer
schriftsteller thomas hürlimann
er schreibt mit spitzen bleistift und
ausgezogenen antennen für das
metaphysische schön dass sie heute hier
sind herr lehmann
juli man sie schreiben in ihrem neuesten
buch auf dem buchrücken es sei wichtig
dass man aus dem bereich schreibe aus
dem man auch träumt haben sie heute
etwas spezielles geträumt ja tatsächlich
aber wie das oft ist genau kann ich mich
nicht erinnern
ich weiß aber dass ich irgendwo auf
einem meer unterwegs war
träume sehr oft von schiffen von mehren
was ist das denn genau dieser bereich
des träumens der auch der bereich des
schreibens ist ja die unser unbewusstes
wie freud oder jungs am besteht ja aus
dem was wir erleben
aus dem was wir lesen aus dem was wir
aber vielleicht auch aus früheren zeiten
in uns haben
also ich könnte mir zum beispiel
vorstellen dass sie mir ein seeräuber
steckt er dann ab und zu nachts zum
vorschein kommt
die träume für mich räumt oder dann bin
ich nachts die seeräuber oder ging der
schiffsjunge in der schatzinsel
dann äußert sich dass wir sie nachts
reiche aus um tag beginnen sie denn
genau deshalb auch weil man nachts
reicher ist als am tag direkt im bett zu
schreiben das ist eher selten ich stehe
meistens auf und aber ohne jede störung
ich lese vorher keine zeitung würde
keine radionachrichten und will dann aus
der nacht in den tag und direkt in
schreiben hinein steigen und das ist die
zeit wo es mir am besten fließt die
träume fließen ja auch wir sind in den
träumen empfangen und diese empfang
möchte ich dann noch aufrechterhalten
wenn der tag beginnt und dann schreiben
sie eben auch sie haben das mitgenommen
mit solch kleinen bleibt
dürften also nicht mit der maschine
können sie besser denken mit dem stift
als mit der maschine
ja das bleistift das ist ja so eine art
fortsetzung der hand finger und es ist
eben so wenn ich mit diesen bleistiften
schreibe und nachher ein blatt vor mir
habe
dann kann ich mich an dieses platz sehr
gut erinnern
also da habe ich ein anderes gedächtnis
als bei einer pc seite die dann viel zu
sauber ist
da mache ich manchmal auch wenn es mir
langweilig ist eine kleine zeichnung
otto oder ich notiere etwas was ich mir
merken muss du bist heute noch zum
friseur oder eben sollten das schreiben
sie dann neben das manuskript habe ich
dann ins manuskript hinein und wenn ich
dann später mich frage wo habe ich da
nicht noch etwas einsatz in deren
richtung dann kann ich mich an diese
plätze drinnen
das könnte ich so mit einem einem
computer beschriebenen blatt eben nicht
auf einer drei und praktische gründe
dass sie das besser memorieren können
einerseits das und zweitens denke ich
dass der bezug zwischen dem schreibenden
also zwischen der hand und dem blatt
papier ist intensiv bereitet es eben
eine fortsetzung ist ja und wie das also
ich bin wahrscheinlich eben auch in der
holz zeit verblieben mit nie ganz in der
elektronik gelernt hat ich benutze die
gerne dann für ein sauberes manuskript
aber eigentlich bin ich ein alter
holzarbeit wenn ein bleistift und ein
papier und aber sie wollten nicht reiner
werden
nein aber ich hätte das gehört zu den
träumen immer gerne selber ein schiff
gebaut und es gab in der nähe von dem
haus wo wir früher wohnten einen
schweinen herrn huber und bei dem war
ich oft herr huber war noch einer der so
einen schrank oder ein stuhl selber
gemacht habe und ich habe dem stunden
lang als knabe zugeschaut
und das ist ja ein ähnlicher vorgang
wenn sie einen text herstellen also dass
man hat dann am anfang noch nichts und
schluss wächst das langsam zu etwas aus
ob da da dass das kann man dann
betrachten das hat man geschaffen
wenn sie sagen sie träumen auch von von
oft von wasser vom mehr verarbeiten sie
dann immer wieder auch teile ihrer
träume in ihrer literatur wahrscheinlich
schon so genau merke ich dass ich okay
es geht eher um die art und weise wie
man so metaphern kommt zu bildern und
der trend ist ja unglaublich war ich an
bildung ich bin immer wieder überrascht
was da nachts auftaucht und wenn mir
jemand ein traum erzählt das geht ja
sehr oft über unsere fantasie bereiche
die wir am tag haben hinaus und wenn das
eben wach ist wenn ich das anzapfen kann
dann schreibt es sich leichter das finde
ich interessant weil sie sagen wenn
jemand ihnen ein traum erzählt es ist ja
so dass seit mindestens der früheren
antike träume extrem wichtig sind oder
in der menschheitsgeschichte also auch
in religionen abkommen offenbarungen
immer wieder in träumen vor
und irgendwie ist das seite aufklärung
bis dann freut und eben auch jung kommen
ist das nicht mehr so im fokus gewesen
und auch heute scheint mir sprechen die
leute wenig über die träume obwohl jeder
jede nacht mehrere träume hat weshalb
ist es wohl so da machen sie eine andere
erfahrung
nein ich glaube schon dass das so ist
ich habe das selber im studium noch
erfahren das hat mit freude zu tun weil
freut habt einfach dann das unbewusste
sozusagen zu so trieb müller erklärt
dass ich der sich nachts dann äußern
kann also er sah
hat sich dann spät korrigiert aber eine
zeit lang hielten jedem klar für
bestimmt von guido also immer
wunscherfüllung seiner wunscherfüllung
und so hat er den traum einfach zu stark
reduziert jung hat das dann wieder
erweitert jung hat dann auch das
kollektive unbewusste und er war das war
auch ein grund für die große
auseinandersetzung zwischen diesen
beiden jung weil er dann von ihnen
abgewendet und umgekehrt auch ja und und
was eben vorher der fall war dass man
die träume wirklich als botschaften aus
dem unbekannten aus dem imaginären das
hat dann freut eigentlich mechanisch
erklärt es gibt eine ursache und eine
wirkung genau es ist nicht mehr eine
quasi auch transzendente macht die einem
auch den traum ein gibt wieder genauer
der fall ja also die in früheren zeiten
da waren die träume dann von den göttern
geschickt genau sie kamen aus einer
anderen welt und also ich habe sehr oft
die erfahrung gemacht das ist vielleicht
sogar so weil ich dinge träumte die ich
jetzt nicht aus mir oder aus meinem
eigenen erleben haben kann
das hat mich dann auch dazu geführt
intensiv jungs oder essen und in dem
sinne freut zu verlassen und hatten sie
da war das ertragreich für sie ja sicher
für ein schriftsteller ist das wichtig
also eigentlich ist es für jeden
menschen wichtig weil mit dem traum
schaffen wir eine art von über dann also
wir kommen von der einen welt in die
andere wir sind ja im traum in der nacht
welt und die besteht dann teilweise eben
ausreichen die unseren tag um zugänglich
sind aber es ist jetzt nicht nur dieses
andere reich für uns wichtig sondern die
tatsache dass wir ich höre man in einer
bestimmten nacht gehe jetzt in eine
andere welt hinein
das heißt ich schaffe einen übergang
transzendieren ich übersteige etwas ich
bin
also nicht vergänglich sondern übergang
lichtblick der für das offen sagen würde
und natürlich ist schreiben etwas das
immer wieder mit solchen übergängen
etwas zu tun hatten sie geben mir da ein
interessantes stichwort bei home er ist
ja die traumwelt auch teil der unterwelt
und spätestens seit die 2015 in der zeit
einen artikel veröffentlicht haben wo
sie einen ein erlebnis nach einer
prostata-operation beschrieben haben
ein auf erweckungserlebnis weiß man auch
dass hier ein bezug zu dieser unterwelt
haben weil sie sich da als lazarus
beschreiben da ich habe oder einladungs
erlebnis hatte nein ich hatte
tatsächlich eine art von lazarus
erlebnis ich bin in der intensivstation
der kardiologie aufgewacht und hatte
keine ahnung was mit mir passiert ist
und musste mich zuerst sagen in welcher
seite der so bin ich der wirklichkeit
also ob sie jetzt noch im diesseits oder
jenseits und dann kam professor doktor
und hat gesagt wir haben sie wolle im
herz überhaupt abgefangen hätten sie
gerne ein espresso das was und wer hat
hier dann jenseits auch als professor
und da habe ich dann gesehen ach so ich
bin da ja auf einer laute bildschirm
herum und und und apparate und ich bin
ja da auf eine intensivstation also da
kam ich langsam wieder zurück aber es
war mir als wäre ich aus einer anderen
welt gekommen
und da fing ich mich an mit dieser figur
lazarus zu beschäftigen und was sie
sagen ich hatte mit der unterwelt das
ist ja eigentlich das interessante figur
sie war vier tage im jenseits und wurde
dann in mitleid gab's lazarus spiele
oder dann gefragt wie war's was hast du
gesehen genauso und lazarus in diesen
spielen hat immer geschwiegen hat kein
wort gesagt
und nicht nur dort auch im evangelium
johannes-evangelium sieht man er äußert
sich nicht zu seiner auferstehung oder
ja und das ist das ist sozusagen das
große geheimnis geblieben was aus
welcher welt kommt er da und und als ich
mich dann mit ihm zu beschäftigen begann
mit dieser figur habe ich festgestellt
bei uns ist er nicht so präsent aber zum
beispiel in russland da geht's los also
wird sehr vererbt als heiliger weil er
ein heiliger ohne eigenschaften ist der
hat nichts gemacht wie oblomow den war
auf dem sofa gelegen hat und wurde
trotzdem dann von jesus eben aus dem
totenreich wieder zurückgerufen
und das fanden die russen auch schlimm
also sie dachten was los ist ein armer
hund ja muss ewig leben genau das finde
ich interessant es wird ja die figur
lazarus wurde literarisch immer wieder
auch irgendwie behandelt und oft wird er
dort als bedauernswert angeschaut weil
er unfreiwillig eben aus der aus dem
totenreich zu ja wieder zurück gerissen
wird deswegen frage ich sie wie ist es
denn ein aufgeweckter zu sein für sie
[Gelächter]
also es ging mir nicht die lazarus das
muss war so sagen also weil sie hatten
nicht jesus der vorgang stein gerufen
hat nein nein das war professor ist also
es blieb ja auch das erspart was daneben
nazis war vier tage trocken und er kam
eigentlich als verwies unter ballon
entstehende an diesem totenreich das so
beschreibt es zum beispiel dann 3 1
dreier von groß schriftstellern und im
mittelmeer bereich ging man davon aus
dass der armee dazu stinkt so er hat den
geruch der verwesung an sich deshalb hat
man ihn immer vermutet in der nähe von
helfen bei der fisch handlung also da wo
die fische ausgenommen werden da weil
man da ist eine verwesung nicht
richter damit er sich verstecken da also
in genua massa wird das große heilige
verehrt und meine erfahrung war dann
tatsächlich aber die man kommt als ein
anderer zurück
also solche erlebnisse auch wenn man sie
in dem sie gar nicht mitbekommt die
haben schon eine große wirkung man
verliert eine existenzielle sicherheit
die man vorher hatte also ich habe zum
beispiel das ganz konkret erlebt ich war
dann in berlin und wollte die karl marx
allee überqueren und sozusagen in meinem
platz muss da sein habe ich das nicht
geschafft ich weiß bis heute noch nicht
warum es gab dann wiederum einen arzt
der mir das erklärt hat dann gesagt
waren sie an einer ampel habe ich gesagt
ja natürlich immer versucht bei der
ampel rüber zu gehen und sagt wie viele
leute waren um sie herum sondern im
durchschnitt 10
und dann sagte er ja wissen das war ein
anästhesist müssen sie bei ihrer
operation landsleute um sie herum
ihr körper hat das registriert sie
wissen es nicht hier unbewusst des
weißes stehen zehn leute um sie herum
sie sind im operationsgebiet und jetzt
schaffen sie es nicht mehr auf die
andere seite der karl marx allee zu
kommen versuchen sich nur da mal rüber
zu gehen was mein weniger als zehn
leuten und es ist eindeutig ich habe das
gemacht und dann geht es also kann so
entspannt
sie hatten ja dann ihre
krankheitsgeschichte ist ja ziemlich
dick sie hatten haben viele operationen
hinter sich
eine operation beschreiben sie ganz
eindrücklich auch da hat ihn der arzt
gesagt vor der operation ihre
überlebenschancen oder sagen wir es
anders die chancen dass sie am leben
bleiben oder sterben die sind quasi 50
50 und sie haben da gesagt in dem moment
wo man wo man diese angst auch verspürt
oder weiß dass es dem ende zugehen
könnte wird die wahrnehmung viel
intensiver können sie das erklären was
sie genau damit mein oder was ich ihnen
da intensiver auch gezeigt hat ja also
das war professor bachmann der mich
operiert hat der mir das leben gerettet
hat dann auch und ich verdanke ihm viel
weil das wichtig war für mich das so
genau zu wissen das sagt ja sie müssen
damit rechnen dass sie nach dieser
operation nicht mehr erwachen ich kann
es ihnen nicht garantieren
und jetzt war ich in dieser nacht das
war die intensivste nacht meines lebens
weil ich wusste so kurz nach fünf kommen
sie um mich vorzubereiten für die
operation und jetzt habe ich aber noch
fünf stunden noch vier noch drei und ich
konnte in dieser nacht die zeit erleben
wie ich das vorher in meinem ganzen
leben noch nie erlebt habe man lebt auf
sein mögliches ende hin immer leben auf
salz bewusst ganz bewusst und ich habe
dann auch empfunden da ist jetzt eine
pforte
ich gehe auf diese pforte zu ich werde
durch diese phase hindurchgehen morgen
abend bin ich vielleicht hier regeln
oder zumindest also in diesem
krankenhaus oder an einem ganz anderen
ort aber ich habe die pforte sport immer
deutlicher gespürt das heißt es waren
wir dann in der empfindung nicht jetzt
in der arzt aber in der empfindung war
es für mich ganz klar dahinter ist etwas
anderes
aber wenn sie eine grenze haben haben
sie eigentlich zwei seiten und ich
spürte dann nicht die andere seite aber
das vorhandensein einer anderen seite
drückte sich in dieser torte aus der ich
näher und näher kam und am schluss war
habe ich sogar abenteuerlich gestimmt da
hat sich dann wahrscheinlich wieder das
thema gewählt das ist auf alle leute aus
verlangsamen der traum wäre ja diese
krankheit hat ja dann letztlich haben
sich schon angedeutet waren in berlin
hat sie zurück in die schweiz geführt
inzwischen wohnen sie im leben sie
wieder dort wo ihre wurzeln her kommen
in walchwil man muss schon sagen
eigentlich ziemlich traumhaft am
zugersee ich komme ja auch von dort ich
kann es beurteilen
wir haben hier einige bilder mitgebracht
wo man sie sieht wie sie auf die regel
zu fahren im abendlicht
sie leben da in einem ehemaligen
fährhaus
da sieht man es auch im bild sind sie
jetzt nebst lazarus auch noch wärmer
geworden
man vermutet dass in diesem in diesem
bootshaus früher der fährmann war als
die ufer noch unsicher über haben hat
man ja mehr den see benutzt
auch gestern wenn er es geschafft hätte
vor der christnacht also durch die hohle
gasse zukommt teil hat ja dann vorher da
erschossen aber der wollte eigentlich
durch meinen fährhaus dann den
wahlfehler berg hoch und über den berg
wieder nach zug und da müssen müssen am
und tausende von menschen eben vorbei
gegangen seien und was ich vorher sagte
mit dem überglücklichen findet dass er
etwas sehr schönes oder wenn ich
manchmal leute auf dem steg sehr oder
eben da bin ich mit dem fisch unterwegs
ich habe ihn gefragt ob ich mal
mitfahren darf
das war sozusagen vom einen ufer zum
anderen geht das ist ja etwas das in
unserer existenz immer wieder passiert
aber eben auch dann wahrscheinlich am
letzten tag dieser existenz dass ich
dann vielleicht ein neues ufer aufzogen
wir wissen es nicht das war ja immer
auch ihr traum oder am in einem schiff
zu haben sie haben uns zuvor angedeutet
sie hätten gerne oder wirken gerne
eigentlich mal ein schiff bauen hängt
das damit zusammen dass sie ein faible
auch für diese übergänge haben
vielleicht aber das schiff das kam ganz
früh das erste was ich gezeigt habe war
ein schiff warum weiß ich auch nicht
dann war ich 15 war wir mit der familie
in italien und in genua und ich war
damals klosterschülerin einsiedeln und
versuchte dann auf ein
also bin auf ein schiff gegangen habe
gesagt ob sie mich mitnehmen als
schiffsjunge das hat nicht geklappt weil
ich nicht teile jänisch kommt das war
ein italienischen bahnhof achtung meine
mutter konnte sehr gut
dann habe ich meine mutter eingeweiht
und sie hat dann zuerst gesagt du musst
doch dieses gymnasium fertig mache ich
bin da sehr unglücklich möchte gern in
die weite welt fahren und plötzlich
sagte sie ich verstehe dich ich komme
mit und kam dann mit mir in die
kapitänskajüte wollen sehr verrannt
wunderschönen italienischen kapitän
empfangen und der sofort also meine
mutter ein espresso angeboten hat und
dann hat sie für mich da gedealt und der
kapitän hat dann gesagt er muss noch mit
der e3 spreche er weiß nicht weil ich
schweizern habe calli ob er mich so auf
dem schiff mit dem kann aber wir sollen
am abend wieder kommt und dann hat aber
in der zwischenzeit der vaart davon
erfahren und so bin ich dann da nicht
aus diesem haufen wegschaut wenn dann
wenn sich an den vater ansprechen dann
dann greife ich denn doch gleich auf sie
haben ja eben ihre vergangenheit wurde
ihnen ja auch immer wieder nach getan
genau weil ihr vater eben auch bundesrat
war hans hürlimann und sie haben
denselben auch literarisierung in diesem
buch hier der große kater das dann auch
verfilmt wurde mit bruno ganz in der
hauptrolle
und ich habe im archiv geschaut und habe
dort einen kleinen ausschnitt gefunden
mit ihrem vater hans für niemann
innenminister zuständig unter anderem
für die eröffnung von autobahnen von
denen es damals eine ganze reihe zu
eröffnen gab ein bundesrat voller
zukunft glauben als der eigene sohn
schwer erkrankt wird aber plötzlich
alles ganz anders
hauptsache politisch am besten gar nicht
wenn er in zehn verschiedenen
politischen laufbahn sich als bundesrat
ist mir böse worte christus ist krank
ein familienfoto aus glücklichen tagen
der bundesrat die gattin die drei kinder
der jüngste neben thomas hürlimann ist
damals noch nicht an krebs erkrankt
nebst dem vater als bundesrat man hört
es jetzt schon war ein sehr
einschneidendes erlebnis in ihrem leben
der tod ihres bruders mit 20 jahren sie
haben mir hier auch ein foto von ihm
mitgebracht
ich habe mich gefragt wie hat eigentlich
sich ihr verhältnis zu ihrem bruder
verändert der ja vier jahre auch krank
war auch an krebs erkrankt seitdem sie
selber eine solche langwierige
krankheitsgeschichte miterlebt haben ja
die unsere beziehung hat sich noch
einmal intensiviert ich kannte vieles
was wir dann wieder fuhr aus der
krankengeschichte von ihm
ich war damals in vielen fällen seien
pflege und er war sehr präsent also in
den einsamsten stunden habe ich im
spital von operationen also danach habe
ich ihnen gesagt matthias hilft du
kannst das kommt also dass und hatte
dann wirklich das gefühl er ist da aber
genauso wichtig war dass dass ich die
andere seite kannte nachdem ich wieder
in berlin waren hat mich meine damalige
frau katja oskamp dann gepflegt und das
ist schwierig also ich war sehr krank ob
sie überhaupt keine ausgebildete
pflegerin und dann habe ich gesagt du
mein bruder und ich wir haben in solchen
fällen immer raus und spiele gemacht und
versuchen wir das doch auch dann hat sie
sich ein schwestern kostüme besorgt mit
täuschen und sie war dann schwester
helga also nicht mehr katja und ich war
herr lehmann von 08 ein stinkstiefel
dann kommt mir sozusagen die die die
pflege in diesem rollenspiel viel besser
ertragen und dann hat sie sozusagen das
häuschen wird und wieder ausgezogen was
ich wieder charakter und ich war wieder
thomas mann das sind alles dinge die ich
matthias zu verdanken hatte also besser
ertragen kann ja und da war ich eben
sozial in der rolle von katja und wusste
auch wie schwierig das ist manchmal
ist es für die angehörigen fast
schwieriger als für den kranken selbst
und da das das da war er dann das waren
seine erfahrung oder für mich eben auch
die erfahrung der klägerseite waren
unglaublich wichtig also das hat mich
durchaus in durchgebracht
sie haben ja in diesem eden jüngst
erschienenen buch abendspaziergang mit
dem kater dass es ein quasi eine
blütenlese aus vier jahrzehnten
literarischen schaffens haben sie einen
nachruf auf ihren bruder drin da ist
sehr berührend ich habe mich dann
gefragt insgesamt es ist stellenweise
ein sehr persönliches buch weshalb
lassen sie denn eigentlich den leser so
nahe an sich ran weil der schriftsteller
der arbeit natürlich mit dem material
aus dem er besteht das ist eben auch das
material aus dem ich träumen außerdem
schreibe ich auch da bin ich experte da
kenne ich mich aus
auf der anderen seite ist es aber so
dass ich natürlich bis zu einem gewissen
grad auch die dinge erzählen von denen
ich ausgehe dass sie auch die lesenden
erreichen also
sie machten aus lesungen die hälfte des
buches ich mache die andere hälfte und
damit jetzt ein text sie erreicht damit
sie auch ihre eigenen geschichten in
diesem text wiederfinden können nur so
wird der text lebendig gehe ich eben in
ganz persönliche erfahrung hinein ihr
persönliches sind sie sind umso eher das
lernt man dann im lauf eines
schriftsteller lebens können sie sich
auch verallgemeinern
also im konkreten steckt meistens auch
schon das abstrakte oder kann man auch
großartige sagen das mythische sie
schreiben nämlich selber in diesem buch
her heimkehr schreiben sie so was wie
das sie durch auch die krankheit
natürlich aus literarische figur auch
erlebt haben die die welt im abschieds
licht schöner wird scheint ihnen denn
die gelebte unendlichkeit nicht
erstrebenswert
ich kann sehr schwer zu beantwortende
frage ich habe das erlebt in einem
moment oder sagen wir schon früher bei
meinem bruder und er wusste er wird
sterben das ist der letzte frühling denn
er erlebt der letzte sommer der letzte
herbst und natürlich haben sich in
farben gezeigt in einer intensität wie
es schöner nicht sein könnte
als ob die welt dauernd hätte haben
wollen und schaue ich bin so schön
geh nicht weg bleibt hier und ich glaube
das ist etwas das vielleicht auch im
sinne ihrer frage schon ein vorschein
einer anderen welt ist dass es das ist
der trost glaube ich wenn man in diese
grenznähe kommt dann hat plötzlich den
eindruck es könnte eigentlich so schön
weitergehen wird die letzten stunden
waren am morgen haben sie geburtstags
werden 70 jahre alt in einem beitrag aus
dem jahre 1985 haben sie folgendes
gesagt zum schriebe köln
es finden wie so dass man das eigentlich
auch das tiefbau mondsüchtigen orange
morgen darum euro um endlich und zwingen
die es auf der tagesordnung
die suche nach der eigenen beweggründe
und der zusammenhang bestimmter der lage
stieg löste konventionelle formen wie
die von der herkunft aus willich
insofern also eine geeignetere familien
dass es wirklich die geblieben
ja da waren sie gerade mal halb so alt
wie sie jetzt sind wie empfinden sie das
sich so zu sehen 35 jahre jünger ach ja
ein bisschen erschreckend und es ist ein
eher fremd und mensch aber es zeigt auch
also wie sehr man sich im lauf eines
lebens danach von sich selber entfernt
also zum beispiel würde ich keinen
dieser setzte heute noch sagen also
würden sie das
das interessiert mich würden sie heute
nicht mehr sagen das schreiben wichtiger
sei als familie
ich würde sagen schreiben war für mich
immer das wichtigste das würde ich so
sagen da wird dann zum beispiel die 20
jahre die ich mit katja oskamp und ihre
tochter clara verbracht der milliardär
tochter haben sie dieses buch das
neueste gerät mit ja und klarer wurde
dann wahrscheinlich eine der wichtigsten
figuren meines lebens mit ihr habe ich
noch mal sozusagen in eine ganz andere
generation auch in einen blick können
wir haben uns sehr gut verstanden sie
sie studiert heute philosophie ich werde
sie wohl auch ein bisschen beeinflusst
haben und diese die kleinst familie die
wir waren in berlin
habt ihr plan und ich das war eine sehr
schöne erfahrung kaputt geschrieben ich
habe geschrieben und klarer hat dann wie
verrückt gelesen nämlich harry potter
und da ist ja auch klar geworden
wie sie zum beispiel eben das
metaphysische vermisst wird also dieses
kind hat das im nicht mehr in der kirche
in der religion erlebt aber dann bei
harry potter geht man ja in die magische
welt und so erkläre ich mir diesen
diesen großer erfolg dass dann eine
ganze generation der man eigentlich die
magie genommen hat das ist so dieser
vertriebs der autorisierung der welt
dass man sagt das ist alles nur noch
eine frage der moral der vernunft dein
kinder wollen menschen gilt wollen dass
magisches und kinder suchen denn über
daneben aus der welt muss dann in die
zauberwelt und da konnte ich auch als
autor bei dieser lesung klar lernen
diese leserin hat ihnen ja dann auch
eine rückmeldung auf ihr schreiben
gegeben sie schreiben es in diesem buch
ihre antwort war auf das was ihr zu
lesen gegeben haben denn und ober gähn
ja weit heimkehr habe ich unglaublich
mit dem stoff herumgeschlagen auch
deshalb weil mich dauernd das leben
wieder in andere zustände katapultiert
hat also dass ich habe den hitler- stars
und das buch bekam sie auch ja und das
buch von mir weg ich hatte es nicht mehr
unter kontrolle
und dann habe ich eben klar weil ich
wusste das ist eine gute lösung habe ich
das was ich dann teilweise harte zu
lesen gegeben und dann kam das zurück
das machen uns getippt und darauf sagt
mariele 50 tantal geräten und auf jeder
zwanzigste obergeil und das ist habe ich
sehr ernst genommen
ich möchte noch etwas fragen was sie
zuvor im einspieler gesagt haben sie
haben gesagt sie schreiben eigentlich
letztlich auch um herauszufinden weshalb
sie überhaupt schreiben haben sie da
herausgefunden weshalb sie schreiben
nein da hat der junge mann eine richtige
antwort gegeben ich glaube über über
meine schreibt sucht
ich kann nicht leben ohne schreiben ein
tag an dem ich nicht schreiben kann ist
für mich ein verloren und tag
und weil ich ein buch fertig schreiben
will bin ich auch aus dieser krankheit
wieder herausgekommen also das hat mich
was das hat mit keine ruhe gelassen ich
wollte heimkehr unbedingt gern
beschreibt dieses buch her und ich
glaube so genau kann man über die sucht
und es ist eine sucht keine auskunft
geben also der mond süchtige weiß nicht
er hat er recht gehabt
warum tun sie schon und anstand jetzt
sind sie als schriftsteller trotzdem so
deutet es schon an ein mann des rennens
und ich habe vor kurzem eugen drewermann
der theologe hier am tisch gehabt er
wurde 80 jahre alt und er hat gesagt man
mache sich oder jeder mache sich von
seiner frühen kindheit eine art mythos
dem rückblick charakteristisch sei für
die eigene persönlichkeit werden haben
sie das auch an sich festgestellt
ich würde jetzt das so nicht formulieren
also ich gehöre nicht unbedingt zu den
menschen oder zu den autoren die
eigentlich auf die da unten suche nach
dem kinderland sind oder nacht ein
paradies der kindheit wie das schon
einmal formuliert hat
mich hat immer auch das interessiert was
in meinem späteren leben passiert ist
und das führt dann auch dann eben aus
diesen aus diesen gefilden fort und weg
und trotzdem ist da natürlich etwas in
uns aber auch da würde ich sagen es ist
nicht nur die erlebte kindheit dieser
prägend ist es ist eine herkunft die
weiter zurückgeht in andere jahrhunderte
in andere zeiträume die in uns dann
weiter lebt und in welcher weise leben
die in uns eben zum beispiel dass wir
doch und träumen oder das wasser habe
ich bin im binnenland geboren also dazu
gesetzlich ist nicht gehabt also was das
das weltmeer hoffe natürlich dass ich so
gut ist ihre bankkonten und aber
trotzdem waren mir eben eine sehnsucht
nach fernen inseln und nach seeabenteuer
was weiß ich
das heißt wir haben da etwas in uns das
noch vor der kindheit liegt da denke ich
sind die waren mühten so wie wir auch
angst haben vorschlagen also wir
bräuchten seit 300 jahren eigentlich in
unseren breitengraden schlamm nicht mehr
so zu fürchten oder ich bin die sind
auch selten giftig aber trotzdem sind
diese ängste noch da das heißt die
ängste wurden uns weitergegeben
die sind in uns immer noch lebendig
aufgrund anderer generation frühere
erfahrung und ich würde sagen das ist
genauso prägend also diese diese vor
welt die jeder mensch mit sich herum
trägt wie eine kindheit da hört man
vermutlich auch schon ihre junge lektüre
raus aber haben sie und erzeugung ist
denn die katze weil die katze
beschäftigt sie über ihre ganzen bücher
hinweg also abendspaziergang mit dem
vater oder der große kater und hier
kommt auch wieder eine katze vor ist das
auch sein symbol oder was beschäftigt
sie denn so an der katze ja wir haben
hier einige exemplare
ja also die katze hat mich und durch
sein gutes beispiel
ich habe die kindheit keine katze also
ich habe jetzt nicht eine katze wieder
gesucht die ich in der einheit von oben
hatte sondern meine frau und ich wir
wollen in emmerting in zürich partei
also es war ihre wohnung hat in brink
und eines tages ist uns ein kart
zugelaufen der kam von einer baustelle
wo sie ihn gefüttert haben er musste
also er wurde eben von den arbeiten
wurde airbus sie gerufen und dann habe
ich sag ich kann nich berufen es ist ein
gattungsbegriff sehen und wenn man ein
mensch mensch nach oft genau und das hat
hat gesagt ja und der hat das ist gut so
dann kann er sich dann bleiben die
vokabel und die das war dann ein
untergrund cartel weil eigentlich sie
hat ja ein mietvertrag unterschrieben
keine haustiere und jetzt musste ich sie
unter vermieter wohnte über uns mit
einem schäferhund und jetzt begann ein
kampf eine gefährliche kontinents eine
sehr gefährliche kombination also ich
hatte keine ahnung von einem kater ich
war damals meist zu hause mit dem kart
zusammen wenn er nicht herum streunte
meine frau nach schauspielerin wagen
unterwegs und über uns hatten wir den
schäferhund und den vermietern wir sind
dann auch ausgeflogen aber ich war
plötzlich der eigenen karte wegen dem
kart w
irgendwann ist er doch ab der
schäferhund durchgedreht und der hieß
übrigens pur berlin
[Gelächter]
und dann mussten wir über nacht eine
frau dort suchen und ich kam ja von der
klosterschule ich kannte ein ziel habe
ich sagte thoben finde ich am ehesten
etwas wo wir über nacht also muss ich
mit frau und katrin kommt kann und dann
waren wir wieder fremd lufti und ich auf
dem land
er war seit generationen in der stadt
jetzt kamen wir da aufs land und ruft
die wollte dann dass ich mit ihm
spazieren
also der hat mich an gestoppt weil er
hatte angst vor dem wald und vor den
tieren ist dann auch mal vermutlich von
einem dachs übel zugerichtet worden weil
einer dax höhle gekrochen ist und dann
fing ich an hinter musste er durch die
wald zu spazieren also die zu revieren
ich war fünf meter hinter ihm und habe
dann grandiose entdeckungen gemacht also
darf das war im späten winter vorstellen
und plötzlich blieb musste völlig stars
sitzen und starrte auf dem boden ich
habe überhaupt nichts gesehen
wenn dann aber mich ihm genähert habe
auch geschaut und da war hat zwischen
dem laub und schneeweißen eine ganz
winzige grüne knospe dann hat er so im
wald den frühling für sich entdeckt und
dh im wege
dieser weg in diesem speziellen blick
der katze hat muss die für sie die liebe
zu den katzen erregt damit muss ich mich
an und ich mache immer neue entdeckung
bei ihm also werden wir unsere
kommunikation wurde immer besser
also zum beispiel mal einen baum
geworden mit dem regenschirm
dann hat musste den schwanz
aufgestellten und von dem moment an
wusste ich wenn ich den schirm hebel
dann heißt das beruft die achtung
gefahren hat er den schwanz so konnten
wir dann auch die straße überqueren
ich habe den schirm gehoben oft den
schwanz dafür das auto vorbei war ging
mit dem schirm und durfte mit dem
schwarzen wir sind über die straße ist
das jetzt schon literatur ist als reales
leben
das ist das leben das wurde natürlich
dann auch also darüber habe ich in
dieses regenschirm lang geschrieben und
der kater da im abendspaziergang mit dem
kater das ist auch wieder muss die
klasse der wurde dann sein freund und
wie sieht es denn aus mit hunden also
jetzt zum beispiel nur billige macht von
oben die davon etwas reden haben kunden
mit denen kann sie nichts anfangen
nein also das habe ich dann erst
entdeckt das gibt wahrscheinlich
hunde menschen und es gibt katzen
menschen ich hätte also mir gefiel bei
musste immer auch dass das nicht
domestizierte haben sie müssen auch
vorstellen also die katze lebt seit
tausenden von jahren in unserem kultur
anschließt das einzige tier das sich der
domestizierung entziehen konnte und das
trotzdem bei uns lebt
die sind ja schon domestiziert
hauskatzen es gibt kratzen die einfach
nur in wohnungen leben das finde ich
schon ziemlich skurril
ja ja aber wenn sie so eine katze dann
in die natur entlassen
das ist das erstaunliche dann wird sie
sofort zb das war bei mir auch so der
kam aus der stadt der hat nie ein
fischreiher gesehen und jetzt wird das
war auf einem unserer ersten
spaziergängen da kam ein schatten also
von so einem rasierten bach entlang flog
die luft den habe ich 24 stunden nicht
mehr gesehen musste ihn dann im wald
suchen also der hatte so eine angst vor
diesem vor diesem schatten das heißt das
abrechnungswesen eines kollektiven
unterbewusstseins aller jung hat das
nicht auch bei katzen ja das
funktioniert auch bei katzen haben wir
genug über katzen gesprochen etwas
anderes dass sich auch durch ihr werk
zieht sie art ist das werk atmet ja auch
die auseinandersetzung mit dem
christentum und sie haben sich als
public intellectual auch immer wieder
etwa über das verschwinden des kreuzes
geäußert dass eben auch bedauert und
ihre religiös entwicklung ist er
ziemlich interessant also sie gingen in
kloster einsiedeln in die in die
klosterschule ins ans gymnasium haben
dort aber einen atheisten club mit 15
gegründet und inzwischen beklagen sie
dass die tridentinische die lateinische
messe nicht mehr durchgeführt wird
wie sowie gilt es das zu verstehen ist
das so der normale wandel der in dem man
immer dem alter nach sagt also im alter
kommt der glaube zurück oder wie soll
ich das interpretieren
ja es ist tatsächlich schwierig
ich kann das nur durch meine geschichte
durch meine biografie erklären als wir
zu bringen
in der stiftsschule einsiedeln waren da
haben wir noch gruppen gefahren das war
eine ordnung aus dem 19 jahrhundert wir
sind jeden tag in die kirche gegangen
und um uns herum außen wandelten die
wandelte sich die welt gab plötzlich
minirock es gab die beatles ist gab die
stones und wir waren immer noch wie eine
insel von großteil abgeschlossen
in diesem neunzehnten jahrhundert und
das hat natürlich irgendwann zu einer
art von explosion geführt also wir haben
dann die gruppen abgeschafft haben uns
gewehrt und das übermaß an religion bei
uns hat dazu geführt dass wir dann eben
einen atheisten club gegründet haben und
und also die unsere die die die schule
in einzelnen ausgezeichneten sondern
hervorragende leo
sie hatten den schlüssel zur bibliothek
sie haben natürlich waren sie in alle
stores und daten und sollten also bis
und mit kampf ums überleben aber schon
bei hegel fing es an das haben den haben
wir dann gelesen und dann kam so leute
wie sagte mappus und so weiter dazu das
heißt wir haben den schlüssel der
bibliothek in unserer hand genommen und
das hat uns natürlich auch beeinflusst
in unserem denken also da stand dann
plötzlich gegen diesen würde sagen
touristischen katholizismus standen wir
groß die schüler eigentlich sehr stark
beeinflusst vom existenzialismus gesagt
und so weiter die dann den glauben
abgelegt haben also die die wir haben
damals zwar noch kunden getragen aber
also ich kann mich gut erinnern wie wir
alle in der kirche standen und wir
hatten so lisa also mit leder einbinden
und so habe ich nicht gelesen also dass
das habe in puncto wie carl ämtern
habe ich jenseits von gut und böse oder
was weiß ich was alles an radikalen
bakulin spa colins revolutionären
katechismus und so weiter dass das haben
wir jeden jahren dran
der fuchs im schafspelz gibt ist das und
und dieses denken hat uns natürlich
beeinflusst
ich habe bei ihnen gelesen dass sie
schreiben während des studiums eben in
berlin dass sie dann in der liebe
festgestellt haben dass sie immer noch
religiös sein war also der atheismus so
was wie ein eine koketterie oder war es
ihnen wirklich ernst damit das war mir
war wie also solche dinge sind ein nie
so ernst wie im pubertären zeiten glaube
ich und also ich war da wirklich ein
überzeugungstäter
und was ich aber unterschätzt habe dass
wir eben so etwas wie metaphysische
antennen haben und ich bin voll dem
zeitgeist erlegen also ich habe freut
gelesen die die seele ist eben ein
psychischer und so weiter also ein trieb
und effekt im auto und da habe ich aus
geglaubt und ich glaube auch dass der
sozialismus die welt verbessern wird bis
etwa 24 da bin ich nach berlin gegangen
und da hat sich gerade das institut für
philosophie in ein institut für
gesellschaftswissenschaften selbst
verändert und es gab an diesem institut
sieben oder acht verschiedene
marxistische gruppen und dann habe ich
plötzlich gesagt nein
zudem will ich nicht gehöre nicht also
dass das waren dann so erfahrung als
kloster schulzeiten
ich will nicht zum asse gehören ich will
ein eigenes denken deinen eigenen
lebensweg und dann kam eben dazu eine
erfahrung die auch gottfried keller
gemacht hat der war ja bei feuerbach in
heidelberg und feuerbach hat mit
religion auch die liebe verworfen hat
gesagt
dass das ist eine einbildung das gibt es
nicht und dann kam ins stocken mit dem
schreiben und grünen heinrich weil er
plötzlich merkt ja ohne die liebe kann
man auch nicht schreiben und und bei mir
war es dann so also dass das ja ich kann
vielleicht einfach so sagen
ich wollte weiterhin eine frau an beten
oder am himmel
das sind metaphysische mörtel und die
wollte ich mir nicht nehmen lassen und
die die da kann dann die erste
verunsicherung da habe ich innerlich
denn ab da ist ein klub verlassen
aber weshalb es dann sozusagen zu einer
radikalen anwendung kam später das hatte
mit verschiedenen stadien erlebnissen zu
tun das was ich als religion erlebt habe
das war eine sehr stark sehr potente
religion dieser katholizismus in der
schweiz damals unsere lehrer da was hat
er das kosten 200 leute also das war
voller blüte wir haben also nicht eine
masche institution attackiert
seltsamerweise ist aber diese stärke
plötzlich wie in sich zusammengebrochen
erloschen also die bezug nehmen also ich
ministrant war war am 3 zuge kirchen am
sonntag brechen von heute sind sie leer
was ist da passiert da ist also ein
zeitloch ein einriss etwas passiert und
als nach
also für mich gibt es eine zeit vor dem
riss da habe ich gegen diese diesen
harten auch in dem sittenstrengen
katholizismus opponiert und als ich dann
sah der ddr ließ stört ist dieses reich
riecht ja zusammen wie damals also das
große kakanien über nacht
da habe ich dann wie die seiten
gewechselt also ich trete keine keine
leiche in dem sehen und da war es mir
dann war es mir dann plötzlich habe ich
gedacht ja wenn wir das abendland das
christentum verlassen was sind wir dann
dann degradieren wir uns zu einer vor
asiatischen halbinsel
was ist denn dieser riss wo sie dann
selber diesen wechsel gemacht haben
ein lehrer den ich in berlin hatte da
haben wir nur so viel gibt das war auch
professor michael landmann ein schweizer
und also sein sohn ist der anwalt
valentin landmann hier in zürich der
bekannte und michael landmann war ganz
mutig also der hat in diesem nach 68
berlin an der fau sozusagen einen
touristischen standpunkt eingenommen
wurde dafür verlangt hatte leere hörsäle
und mir hat einfach der mut dieses
mannes imponiert der musste sie denken
alle anders aber ich sage meine meinung
und land man hat dann damals denn blut
da sich erinnert der in seinem buch über
die orakel von einem kapitän da muss
erzählt der fährt an einer insel vorbei
und auf diese insel rufen sie wenn du
zur nächsten insel kommt nach parodist
anmeldedaten der große bahn ist tot
da muss fährt dann mit seinem schiff
dahin und ruft zur insel hinüber
der große panis tobt und auf der insel
entsteht ein mehr geschrei ist etwas
ungeheuerliches passiert man hat das
damals in verbindung gebracht das im
dritten jahrhundert nach christus
mit dem aufkommen des christentums also
der antike gott die antiken götter sind
tot es kommt eine neue christliche welt
eben
und land man hat damals gesagt ja was
lernen wir aus dieser geschichte das
götter sterblich sind und vielleicht ist
es einfach so dass diese art von
christentum in dem wir gelebt haben eine
dauer von 2000 jahren hatten hatte und
dass wir nun in eine neue zeit übergehen
ich weiß es nicht ich sehe nur dass eben
eine gesellschaft die sich eigentlich
noch auf ihre christlichen wurzeln
berufen müsste man kann sagen auf
jüdisch-christliche auch von der antiken
und damit mehr antike geprägte welt die
interessiert das nicht mehr
und wenn sie das nicht mehr interessiert
dann stirbt diese welt weg dann
verlieren wir unsere herkunft und damit
wahrscheinlich auch unsere zukunft sie
haben da ja einen eher pessimistische
sicht sie haben das auch schon öfter
geäußert denn in interviews und zweiter
eben wie sie auch beklagen dass das
kreuz verschwindet ich frage mich
trotzdem jetzt in dieser art von von
auch pessimismus haben ihre antennen
dann trotzdem noch ein signal empfangen
ihre metaphysischen antennen die sie
zuvor angesprochen haben ich glaube ja
also da wurde dann auch die zb die liebe
wurde wichtig also wenn man sich
verliebt es gibt ja so und so viele
schöne frauen und man verliert sich in
die eine dann stellt man sich die frage
ist es gerade diese eine da habe ich
dann platon gelesen und und und fand das
hochinteressant dass er eben gesagt wir
haben so etwas wie eine animalis ein gut
bild und das suchen wir dann wieder und
wenn wir es gefunden haben dann sagen
wir sie ist es das können wir dann
sozusagen im augenblick sagen und ebenso
zum beispiel was ich ihnen was es vorher
erzählt habe in dieser nacht vor der
operation wenn man sich eine fahrt
ernährt und wenn dann plötzlich spürt ja
da drüben ist etwas was ich schau ist
nur eine empfindung aber um das wort von
nietzsche zu gebrauchen das war dann die
stunde einer wahren empfindung ich habe
plötzlich gespürt es könnte dadurch
tatsächlich eine welt sein
die welt erwartet das hat dann mit trout
so gar nichts mehr zu tun aber ich denke
es brauchte die metaphysischen antennen
das sind diese moment zu spüren morgen
haben sie geburtstag und kurz darauf
weihnachten als kind waren sie überzeugt
dass diese weihnachtstage die geschmückt
sind von steinen haben sie gesagt sie
haben hartnäckig geglaubt dass
ihretwegen in den gassen die sterne
aufgehängt werden und an den
christbäumen die kerzen brennen die
weihnachtsgeschichte das war ihre
geschichte dann haben sie denn
realisiert das ist ja ganze
weihnachtsbaum nicht ihrer person galt
ja spät es war ganz eigene hat also war
so meine mutter war am 24 spieltag mit
mir und ihm
mir ging es sehr schlecht sie hat starke
blutungen und dann hat man hat mein
vater gesagt gebt ihr das kind also das
hält sie vielleicht am leben und fürchte
sie würde sterben
und dann hat man mir das immer so
erzählt als weihnachtsgeschenk quasi du
warst dann bei seiner mit so im
spitalbett und dann kamen engel also das
war das erlebnis meiner mutter und meine
mutter mal etwas erstaunt weil der ober
engel stang stille nacht der ober engel
sah aus wie oberschwester hecklingen und
sagen auch ein bisschen falsch und sie
dachte dann seltsam also dass die im
himmel auch wieder so falsch singen
haben
das hätte ich habe das erwartet guten
musikunterricht ja genau und aber dann
hat sie irgendwann realisiert
wir sehen ja immer noch im krankenhaus
wie frauen hoffen und danach eine
schwester geboren wurde und so weiter
und diese diese geschichte stimmt
natürlich für mich herr vorhaben mit dem
zusammen was in dieser nacht geschaffen
über also die lichter da aufleuchteten
und ich glaube es war schlicht eine
narzisstische kränkung was ich erfahre
es geht da um jesus undicht licht licht
und dichter wert ist so drei oder vier
jahre alt gewesen sein
das würde mich weiter interessieren
leider sind wir schon am schluss des
gespräches angekommen eine letzte frage
an habe ich an sie
der philosoph jacques derrida hat ja mal
diese sonderbare dieses sonderbare
erlebnis beschrieben wie es ist wenn man
unerwartet von der eigenen katze nackt
beobachtet wird und da hatte ich dann
sehr geschämt ich habe mich gefragt wer
sind sie eigentlich in den augen ihrer
katze ja wenn ich das wüsste da müsste
ich sehr viel mehr über mich aber ich
weiß deshalb dass der ich da so ergangen
ist katzen haben ja diesen ganz
intensiven blick und ich glaube ich bin
froh dass mufti mich nie so gedacht
da wäre ich wahrscheinlich ließ diese
intensität wäre ich nicht gewachsen
gewesen des blicks ganz herzlichen dank
für dieses gespräch herr lehmann dankte
ihm und wünsche ihnen sowohl war ebenso
und einen schönen geburtstag dax am
weihnachtsmorgen sehen sie bei uns einen
film zu mieten und jetzt gleich empfängt
sie barbara bleisch mit einer sendung
zum trost der philosophie
wir sehen uns wieder im neuen jahr bis
dahin wünsche ich ihnen wunderbare
festtage und bedanke mich für ihre treue
[Musik]